so once again I've managed to decimate
meal humor
[Laughter]
so let's try for this one then let's
head over to our vacuum desiccator what
Neil's doing is actually connecting the
desiccator to the vacuum pump what that
will do is suck all the air molecules
any moisture absolutely everything
that's in this desiccator that's
molecular size out so the idea is that
those eggs will be under vacuum and
essentially it's as if they're in space
there are no atmospheric pressure
nothing like that affecting the egg and
therefore there's nothing to stop the
the fund and inside the egg pushing
outwards oh sudden popping the chocolate
shell and then it's really coming out so
it's under the vacuum and so all the
tiny air bubbles that were in the
fondant are gradually expanding and
exploding out and what we're seeing
there is a foam foam egg we firmed up
we'll see what happens when we actually
reach this the atmospheric pressure back
into the vessel so we'll turn the vacuum
off oh wow not got the vacuum anymore
the pressures being exerted back onto
the egg which is why all the fondant
collapse down really quickly there we go
so you can see it actually split like
that do you know that looks like me does
it look like
another clean up drug for me oh it does
like a cleanup job for now and chocolate
or particularly cocoa butter has a very
complicated crystal structure you can
have several different forms and if you
get the wrong form the chocolate melts
at too low a temperature makes your
hands all sticky so there is some
extremely cunning chemistry in getting
the chocolate to crystallize so this is
potassium chlorate so I call it bottled
oxygen because it's a simple chemical
and inorganic material which contains
lots of oxygen so when you heat it it
gives up all that oxygen and then it can
react we've broken up the lumps now we
need to fuse it so to fuse the salt we
have to melt it
and you can see we have a Bunsen burner
the salt you can see is starting them
out
it's fusing
and we ready to start putting in some
sugar approximately like a creamy so yes
here is our egg in a tongs and now we're
gonna try and release the goo go
on the Guam
that's where the sugar is
I think that's final chemical proof that
the goo is where is that
No
so once again I've managed to decimate
[Music]
so again so once again I managed to make
a mess in my friends few word anyway I'm
gonna go and give a lecture now so see
you later meal if we think about the
cream egg the lovely gooey stuff which
is really rich in sugar and nice and
runny and mobile which can react very
quickly with the potassium chlorate is
trapped inside a box of chocolate and
the chocolate wasn't particularly
reactive so once we break open the egg
and release the goo it reacted very very
rapidly with all the oxygen given off by
the potassium chloride decomposing to
see the wonderful Flair fantastic very
very hot though managed to break our
evaporating basin I'd expect that the
sugar will react chemically quite
differently from the chocolate because
the sugar contains carbon hydrogen
oxygen approximately in the formula C
h2o whereas the fat's in the in the
chocolate are much more rich in hydrogen
much less oxygen fill this up with
liquid nitrogen if we can
we're gonna drop in Capri scream egg see
what happens
so the coverage cream egg which is
actually quite warm as I've been
handling it it's in this room it's
causing the liquid nitrogen to evaporate
really quickly we're gonna let this
freeze in here for a while okay so we
have our cream egg freezing over here in
liquid nitrogen but when I was a student
my teachers always told me to be a good
scientist you have to do control
experiments so what we're gonna do is
well see what happens when we smash The
Cranberries cream egg that's at room
temperature so this is at about 25
degrees or so so it makes a bit of a
mess which Neil is gonna have to clean
up I'm afraid okay so we've had a cream
egg sitting in liquid nitrogen for a few
minutes now so we're gonna see what
happens when we hit it with our mallet
so here's our frozen cream egg so this
one has been it's out about minus 200
degrees C so it's frozen solid I'm gonna
hit it with my mallet and see what
happens very quite a nice mess here
[Laughter]